holy Sh did I just wander into the
beginning of take it to gain character
wakes up suddenly from nightmares cliche
Jason Bourne one of the most wanted men
in the world has not changed his
appearance even one iota since becoming
a wanted man despite making retain her
hair drastically in the last movie in
making Nikki change her hair drastically
in the next movie Bourne himself I know
he's good as is thanks no one will
recognize it just bits and pieces you
would think since Harry has a connection
to Baltimore he'd be able to piece these
memories together in a short time we
wouldn't need eight movies to figure
them out oh I'm sorry my narration just
made use of a one-time-only time Turner
and it drifted in from another franchise
carry on journaling in case you confused
it with Burrell in North Dakota
understand too using the full allocation
for this part it's where we came out the
CIA not know how much money was going to
be involved before this mission started
I never understood why of all people
they decided to pin this on Jason Bourne
a guy that's been off the grid a couple
years and has shown a propensity for
revenge violence but more importantly
can you get a fingerprint like this from
anything other than an actual
fingerprint on an object like sure
Bourne was printed as part of his
government service but can you really go
pull that ink and paper print and create
this I don't think so so I'm sending it
until proven wrong
Pecos oil chief executive officer URI
drank off in just six years great
coffees turn pecos into an oil Empire
exposition by news broadcast also this
is just like when Colonel Stewart was
watching the news broadcast about
himself at the beginning of die hard to
- the naked aerobics of course depose
now why is it every time there's a
meeting between people doing illegal
things the person arriving is always
late and what does this have to do with
a narrative at large except nothing it's
a wonder they were able to hide here for
any length of time at all or even tried
to considering how much white people
stand out in this place I didn't they go
to Australia or something who runs this
close to the water in tennis shoes a
moron that's who or someone who hates
shoes
I highly doubt the overprotective born
from the last movie that wanted to wipe
down footprints in the hotel would allow
this photo to be taken this is an
exciting montage of born running on the
beach and Murray looking through his
journal filled with out-of-context notes
that aren't going to help us understand
anything I'm good I guess this is called
padding first off Bourne spelled
apartment with two PS on the sheet
behind the top one then he realized his
mistake on the next one my silliness for
the idea that he can apparently remember
his apartment well and drew a picture of
a staircase having looked at some of
these notes in borns journal most of
these are total that we
never help you remember anything plus
who was I is basically the top question
you're trying to answer and it's in the
middle of the journal sternal was
specifically made for a movie montage
wasn't here's the cliche cotton candy
vendor in Gao India serving all the tens
of tourists teaming in the streets Jason
Bourne just sees a car it's driving
doing what cars do and yet somehow knows
it's a guy coming to kill him for blown
yeah well you're hiding in a town that's
99% not white people and you never
changed your appearance this was
basically inevitable why didn't you go
to England this is a huge head start but
the movie will still make a car chase
out of this that's twice now I've seen
the same guy so I'm in town he's at the
telegraph office what kind of world is
born living where he somehow doesn't see
someone he's seen at least twice in the
same town especially if he's paying
attention and memorizing everyone's
faces here take the wheel
you're gonna dry Jason kills marine he
was keeping a loaded gun in this glove
box in a vehicle park and abandoned with
the windows down this water is way more
green than I think it should be even if
the water and GAO's famously polluted
it's not this green this is the
cinematographers filter dialed up to 11
premature confidence that the job was
done also job well done sunglasses in
case you confused it with Moscow British
Columbia
- Donnell yeah why trust this assassin
to do the job but not trust his word
that is done did you hear about the
incident and speculate maybe Bourne
survived or are you just adding tension
to the plot for later also this assassin
somehow had good enough sight through
his rifle scope - headshot his target
but somehow did not see that said target
the driver was female
I know Bourne wants to see if they
recovered Marie's body but does he just
assume the assassin is as stupid as this
movie suggests and isn't lying and wait
for an opportunity just like this one
he's really dry excessively dry for a
guy who recently climbed out of a river
during the time laying low Murray
decided to take numerous photo booth
pictures of herself so Boren could
dramatically burn them later I guess but
who took photo I mean seriously this
assassin couldn't have just waited here
for a couple of hours to see if Bourne
came back I'm pretty sure I don't trust
this guy since he was the cook in the
Hunt for Red October in case you
confused it with nipples in the teeth
you know what just gonna add 5 cents for
these obvious place names and this movie
will get an overall discount and I won't
have to point out each one I know any
CIA people who have been briefed on
borns capabilities so stupidest to
believe he'd leave behind an obvious
fingerprint like this did I not know how
Bourne borns I thought redstone was a
black ops off-the-books kind of program
that much of the CIA could plausibly
deny existed but apparently there are
well kept files for this thing look
you're not gonna believe this Jason
Bourne's pass
just why waste precious seconds with the
you're not going to believe this intro
if the information is so goddamn
important also yes he shouldn't believe
that at least you should know he's doing
it on purpose I mean these assholes act
like they never CIA before got a
question does anyone question why Bourne
would have been so stupid as to get
himself caught with his own passport in
Naples and maybe try and talk about this
on a more secure line he's asking two
men what a highly experienced field
officer I want that area no doubt the
amazing super agent got all this the
first time you heard it but he's
rewinding it several times because I
guess the C needed some dialogue this
poor girl she finally gave up that
ballet hip-hop dream and settled for a
life in the CIA she had a rough year or
two back in the day with Jason Bourne's
amnesia but she settled nicely in
Amsterdam country of drugs sex and very
little CIA level espionage and now he's
going to storm back into her life and
flip it upside down planes trains and
automobiles ah the old government fleet
of Chrysler minivans routine it
regularly frightened the Russians during
the late 80s but lost its mojo once the
Russians figured out the translation for
soccer mom this asshole who somehow
knows Bourne is inside his apartment
after entering some house he has no
clues outside his apartment always
bugged me if he can Punk since born
inside the house in a few moments based
on nothing why can't he sent something
as a Miss while outside his home born
like a king amateur is distracted by a
king phone ringing shaky-cam one-on-one
fight scenes are the only derogatory
thing I can say about these movies fun
also born has a magazine and this dude
has a knife yet born still wins so u.s.a
u.s.a u.s.a Oren Riggs this thing up and
it just happens to work right when the
bad guys get to the front door cops
respond immediately something that just
happened one second ago that she was
entertaining for sure but what did Jason
Bourne benefit by going to that assholes
apartment the assurance that he's being
hunted they even get that other Tritt
stone agents home in a dress anyway you
killed two people born ironically he did
kill two people in Berlin ages before
the deaths Landy is talking about which
is just enough to confuse and bother
Bourne for some reason send her alone 22
give her your phone what if I can't find
her Jamie she's standing right next to
you okay
good scene and everything but there is
no reason why Landy would pretend she
doesn't know where Nikki is other than
to have this great moment where Landy
realizes board is watching her right now
also there are at least 30 trained CIA
agents in this room yet they don't all
storm out and immediately swarm the
surrounding buildings facing these
windows to catch form instead they stare
and wonder
must be part of the training I guess
these are some of the most visible
snipers I've ever seen forget Bourne
I'm surprised everyday citizens aren't
running and screaming right now
because they're obvious as hell
smuggling stuff on Conklin it was
something to do with a Russian
politician meskhi oh come on if the last
57 minutes are to be believed you've
only been able to remember bits and
pieces of things something about a train
something Chris Cooper said to you all
they now Nicki says something about a
Russian politician and you come up with
neski just like that wouldn't Gorbachev
or Yeltsin or Putin come up first
the CIA in town to catch born in part
due to the neski murders he knows
something about the neski case are not
monitoring internet circuit traffic for
the word neski surprisingly the
newspaper articles in this sequence
actually have real written articles that
go along with them but this article
clearly plagiarizes the previous one
okay I understand killing the kid
underling who figured out the roots what
I don't get is leaving his body here at
the site of the original crime as though
that won't cast immediate suspicion on
anyone and everyone affiliated with this
case including you this is a live
project Jericho bones memories return at
a rate consistent with this movie's plot
development which is amazing so here's
born once again going into a place using
his real identity and what not so that
Landy will know where he is but how does
he expect her to put two and two
together about this hotel how he killed
a Russian politician and his wife and
how complan and Abbott are involved
luckily Abbott will suddenly freaked out
about Bourne visiting this place and say
everything he needs to say on tape so
that Bourne can win even though born by
himself can't prove anything also I find
it amazing that the one assassination
Bourne is trying to remember has
something to do with the very thing that
put this movie's plot into motion Bourne
enters this door by using something also
do you really need to break it to 6:45
aren't most of these hotel rooms the
same especially if they're on the same
floor and across the hall from each
other you need to be in the exact room
to remember all this Lorne remembers he
actually killed these people with the
requisite amount of blurriness
even if Boren hadn't seen your careless
footstep shadows already you're making
enough noise especially with the yelling
I'm sure he'd already know you were here
long before he was in any danger also I
guess it's a good thing room 645 was it
available and there was no one in it so
he could walk around and remember he
killed those people a long time ago and
everyone thinks he's in room 644 right
now born casually jumps 50 feet off a
bridge onto a rooftop onto a boat and
suffers nothing from the effort and no
one from cop to spectator saw that the
very definition of convenient smart lame
sure convenient us absolutely
I recognize this room from a photo no
you don't they found Annie's Owens body
this guy does not go on to finish the
sentence by saying in the exact spot
where we originally found borns
fingerprints they can't prove anything
without board this movie is a clear case
of where the villain somehow made life
worse for himself by trying to kill
someone who didn't need to be killed
once you got the Dion files you didn't
need to hunt down an unkillable assassin
in India with amnesia who was living
like peacefully with his girlfriend
Landy obviously suspect something is up
with Brian Cox because he was the early
2000s go-to villain and she walks right
into his room without him answering but
isn't even armed or has backup in case
this guy is as dangerous that she thinks
he is I see they've entered one of those
PG 13 strip clubs I've been hearing
about that somehow make money movie
gives us no explanation for how Bourne
figures out these particular Russian
guys tried to kill it it just cuts
straight to him in Russia going ape for
a movie that spends a lot of time
showing us Bourne figuring down this
seems out of character
only this random woman not only knows
that Ness keys daughter moved away but
knows the exact location where she moved
wait a minute what's that someone I
can't possibly see from here walking in
the park with his back turned to me must
be bored this is just an awful shot from
someone hired to kill someone like this
he's gone slit Karl Urban go after
seeing some ID but apparently don't ask
any questions about the man he was
trying to kill or even attempt to help
him out
bad guy utterly guesses where the good
guy went but is 100% correct cliche yeah
one woman walked out of that grocery
store with mild urgency he must be in
there
map reading while driving is actually
three times more dangerous than texting
while driving but whatever it's a movie
and we're rooting for this guy so also
reading about this fast at these speeds
and this kind of rush would be
impossible even for data from Star Trek
let alone Jason Bourne this is some
next-level computing both going on right
before our eyes
treating elune while driving is even
more dangerous than reading a map wow
this guy is Superman in a car I'll just
accept it Bourne is driving a taxicab
but this movie will have you believe
he's in one of those souped-up fast and
furious vehicles complete with Nas adi
old drive-in - eight lanes of traffic
and hope my pursuers get it worse than I
do routine works every time it is a life
you I'm a killer running from a killer
we matter more that anyone survives this
somehow with all these witnesses Bourne
still escapes into the ether after this
also shouldn't there be way more than
cars backed up in this tunnel this is a
four-lane tunnel are you telling me
traffic on this bitch is so minimal that
borns carnage is only backed up nine
cars mushy onion this asshole couldn't
just meet her a normal way did you have
to be a spooky dick about this surely
someone like him was trained in the art
of meeting strangers without breaking
into their apartment like taking notes
from that pickup artist mystery asshole
or that style asshole oh you're afraid
of my gone let me put it away instead of
you know putting away before you even
showed up and born for all his genius is
an idiot that's beautiful
how did you know he spoke English did
you detect that Boston accent in his
Russian even if you did it it's a sin
that the highly trained super assassin
has a Boston accent to detect hey I
killed your parents in cold blood and
made it look like your mom killed your
dad hope you can forgive me I mean how
do you even convince yourself to come
here but I don't say that bulk do it
sure you feel better but how is her
mental health right now do you even care
get some rest pan it tired he could have
literally guessed that from anywhere
I figured while I'm at it why not just
shoot my buddy take his job give it to
his sworn enemy hike up gas prices bar
my village club a baby seal hit the hash
pipe and join the national god I could
be elected president I think about the
sheer number of people who pulled
together to save my sorry ass and I can
barely comprehend it the cost of my
survival was in the hundreds of millions
of dollars
what happens if the engine stops we are
I'll see you again this side or the
other I like to think the last thing
that went through his head
other than that bullet was to wonder how
the hell Andy Dufresne ever got the best
of it touching our hands wondering why
it's time for say
guys around here I'll tell you you play
for a living it's like any other job you
don't gamble
you grind it out your goal is to win one
big bet an hour that's it
Pamela Landy I know you're out there I
can feel you now I know that you're
afraid what you're afraid of us
you're afraid of change